what I loved about this this movie is we
were characters in a game but we were
very much it was such a metaphor for
life how we all we have one game that
we're living in and we were you know
doing one job and you go off on this
hero's journey and when you come back
you're doing the same job but you're
changed your different for having gone
on the on the journey she was going to
be kind of more of a drill sergeant more
of this kind of analysis you know the
and there's still some of that in there
with the platitudes and the but then the
really kind of the huge break was when
the backstory came into play that she
became this kind of wounded vulnerable
you know a person that that uh this
whole you know heroic kind of tough let
down our guard once and it will never
happened we look at it in storyboards we
have some of the actors in recording
certain scenes other times we have just
some scratch voices in there to see
what's working what's not working and we
actually then meet with the directors at
Disney and we go up to Pixar only meet
with those directors and it's about kind
of deconstructing the film and finding
out what's working and what's not
working and that's when ideas like how
do we ground Calhoun come in because you
sit there and say well what if she did
have this tragic backstory then we
immediately get all of this information
as to who this character is and and I'm
working with and that's why it was great
working with Jane and John and Sarah and
Jack because they had the patience to
kind of let this process work you know
that they kind of came in on faith that
okay we're going to get there you know
we're going to have to kind of feel
around a little bit in the beginning but
then when things when the big pieces
started to land it was like okay this is
you know the this feels good I remember
after the first session I said to rich
is this along the lines of what you want
you said yeah yeah yeah that's it
because I kind of went in and do did
what I do and he said yeah you know
basically that's why you're here is to
do it that way and they videotaped us
and every time I went to a session there
would be two or three months maybe four
or five months in between sessions and
the character will have evolved and I'm
noticing that she kind of is starting to
look like me I mean I they'll be
we used my body as an inspiration and I
started to see with fix it Felix how he
was moving his mouth slightly like Jack
McBrayer and you know these guys are as
geniuses the guys and gals who do the
animation and so for me it was basically
coming in every couple of months the
script oh maybe even reading the same
scene that I read two months ago but
it's light changes and I the story
started to deepen and because we do it
over the course of several years we're
always picking parts of the movie that
are working and we focus on those areas
and put all our energy to get that into
production while we give the creative
team more time to think artistically
about how is this next world hero's duty
going to evolve and what's the story
line going to be for this character or
how does the scene become better so we
we get this great opportunity to kind of
go in at pieces and moments of the time
to develop that part of it while the
other side is still kind of in the the
cooking stage if you will we had a
designer who names Lorelei bauvais who's
from Spain who was very instrumental in
the designing of sugar rush um because
we knew early on that it was going to be
this candy world and we wanted to
develop something new you know not just
a cliched kind of Candyland world or
Hansel and Gretel's which is housed kind
of thing that used gingerbread house
that you've seen before and Lorelei
early on mentioned that that when she
was a little girl in Barcelona that she
would look at the architecture of
gauteng you know like a park well and
all those and the Sagrada Familia the
Cathedral in Barcelona that those
buildings always reminded her of like
candy houses and like these kind of
gingerbread homes and things and that
became kind of the spark you know for
that was the foundation for sugar rush
yeah you know I've made my living in
voiceover for many years and I love it
it's one of my favorite things to do so
and in being in an animated movie went
before you're a celebrity is kind of the
brass ring and so I got to grab that
brass ring I was thrilled it was
actually an ambition of mine to be in a
Disney movie
I never that was so preposterous it
wasn't even on my bucket list